[Music]
in ursula k le guin's fourth earth sea
novel to hanu we don't actually find out
who the
chief antagonist the enemy
is in the the novel until the
very end of it in the last two chapters
and as it turns out it is an evil wizard
a mage actually one who has been trained
at the isle of roke who has learned the
high arts and who is using those arts
for evil and is an evil person himself
in the things that he
expresses and does the attitudes that he
has his name is aspen he's a
young man and he was hired three years
before the the main events in the book
from uh the isle of roke for the
lord of ray alby
and he comes to gant he you know does
the professional courtesies he needs to
do and then he
mainly sticks to
his place as we're going to see carrying
out something quite evil
so we first encounter him
as ogean dies and we have this
description when the wizard came down
from the mansion house a tall young man
with a silvery staff of pine wood
and the other came up from god poor to
stout middle-aged man with a short youth
staff auntie moss did not look at them
but ducked and bowed and drew back
gathering up her poor charms and
witcheries
is the grave dog asked the wizard of god
port yes said the wizard of ray alby it
is dug in the graveyard of my lord's
house and he pointed toward the mansion
house up on the mountain i see said god
port i had thought our mage would be
buried in all honor in the city he's
saved from earthquake my lord desires
the honor said ray alby
and
they they go back a little bit you know
back and forth about this the wizard
from gone port is a very diplomatic
person
the young wizard from reality is kind of
uh
a jerk
and tenar says his name
was ihaul when they're when they're
talking about him dying nameless his
wish was to lie here where he lies now
both men looked at her
the young man seeing a middle-aged
village woman simply turned away she is
beneath him she he is contemptuous of
her
gantport stared for a moment and said
who are you i am called flint's widow
gohan who i am is your business to know
but not mine to say at this
the wizard of ray alby found her worthy
of a brief stare take care woman how you
speak to men of power
and the the young wizard is already you
know taking an animus
towards her and what we see is that
he's uh he views himself as a man of
power
and there's two sides to that a man and
of power if you don't have power you're
nothing to aspen you you don't matter
and he's a man he's very misogynistic
it's clear
that he hates tennar
not just because she's accorded a
certain power but also because she's a
woman
and she has the temerity to speak up uh
against him so he's either contemptuous
or he's hateful or he
is fawning you could say in certain
respects when he recognizes that
somebody actually has power and he hates
tenner it's very clear
that he hates her guts
for being a woman and being who she is
she is the princess or the priestess or
however you want to put it the one who
brought with ged the ark mage the ring
of ereth akba she is a person who is
honored and he cannot stand that
what we find
is that um
when she goes to the the manor
he's waiting
she strode on to meet him it was aspen
the wizard of the mansion house he stood
gracefully leaning on his tall pine
staff as she came out into the road he
said are you looking for work no
my lord needs field hands this hot
weather is on the turn the hay must be
got in so he's deliberately doing this
as she knows to goha flint's widow what
he said was appropriate and gohan
answered him politely no doubt your
skill can turn the reign from the he
fields till the haze in but he knew she
was the woman to whom ogin dying had
spoken his true name
and given that knowledge what he said
was so insulting and deliberately false
as to serve a clear warning she had been
about to ask him if he knew where the
man handy was instead she said i came to
say to the overseer here that a man he
took on for haymaking left my village as
a thief and worse not one he'd choose to
have about the place but it seems the
man's moved on
aspen said with an effort i know nothing
about these people
and she says or she goes on she had
thought him on the morning of ogen's
death to be a young man a tall handsome
youth with a grey cloak and silvery
staff he did not look as young as she
had thought him or he was young but
somehow dried and withered his stare and
his voice were now openly contemptuous
and she answered him in gohan's voice to
be sure i beg your pardon she wanted no
trouble with him she made to go her way
back to the village but aspen said wait
so now he's going to force the issue
a thief and worse you say but slander's
cheap and a woman's tongue worse than
any thief so you see the misogyny
already there
you came you come up here to make bad
blood among the field hands casting
calumny and lies the dragon seed every
witch sews behind her did you think i
did not know you for a witch when i saw
that foul imp that clings to you do you
not think do you think i did not know
how it was begotten and for what
purposes the man did well who tried to
destroy that creature but the job should
be completed you defied me once across
the body of the old wizard and i forbore
to punish you then for his sake and in
the presence of others but now you've
come too far
and i warn you woman i will not have you
set a foot on this domain and if you
cross my will or dare so much as speak
to me again i will have you driven from
ray albee and off the overfell
thrown off the cliff with the dogs at
your heels have you understood me and
tenar says no i've never understood men
like you so she's not giving in to him
as he's expecting and indeed demanding
he's threatening her he's he's also
saying i know you're a witch and that
you know a child that you have there is
a foul imp who should be killed he's
expressing his hatred
and he attempts to cast a spell on her
at that point in time he has his staff
raised up the magic is already starting
to happen
and fortunately two of the king's men
are there and they
do honor to tenar which won't allow that
to happen but
that is not
the end of the story we also find out
that he is involved
in stealing life
from the grandson
of the lord of rey alby
a very
disgusting prospect right
moss tells this story tenner had asked
her about the wizard aspen not telling
her the whole story but saying he'd
threaten her
so she she talked with the others they
all hated aspen and were so quite ready
to talk about him their tales must be
heard as half spite and fear
but
she found out that
in until aspen came three years ago the
younger lord the grandson had been fit
and well though a shy sullen man scared
like she said then about the time the
young lord's mother died the old lord
had sent to rock for a wizard what for
with lord ogie and not a mile away and
they're all witch folk themselves in the
mansion aspen had come he paid his
respects and no more to ogen and always
most said stayed up at the mansion
since then less and less have been seen
of the grandson and it was said now that
he lay day and night in bed
like a sick baby all shriveled up said
one of the woman who'd been into the
house on some errand but the old lord a
hundred years old or near or more
the old lord was flourishing full of
juice they said and one of the men for
whom they would only have men weighed on
the mansion and told of the one of the
women that the old lord had hired the
wizard to make him live forever
and that the wizard was doing that
feeding him the man said off the
grandson's life so there is this
vampirism almost going on drawing from
the weaker grandson for the stronger
lord
for pay or profits
another evil act
we find also aspen
not only attempts to cast a spell on
tenor but succeeds in doing so
and there's this you know description of
like the smell of burnt hair
and it produces a deep confusion
in tenor one of the things that's
particularly insidious
about this spell
is that tenor is unable to really make
sense
out of what's happening or how to
deal with it
here's the description as soon as they
entered the house tener had knew someone
had been there while they were in the
village it smelled of burnt meat and
hair the coverlet of their bed had been
disarranged when she tried to think what
to do she knew there was a spell on her
it had been laid waiting for her she
could not stop shaking and her mind was
confused slow
unable to decide she could not think
she could she thought in her own
language
i cannot think in heartache i must not
she could think in kargash not quickly
and
this is you know going to go on for for
quite a while as a matter of fact until
they get out of there and managed to get
down to the harbor and get
on the sea but
not all of the effects of the spell
are gone
it also makes her unable to really
articulate or unwilling to articulate
what is happening there's a very
interesting description while she's on
the boat
she says that
she's asked who is it that laid the
spell on you and she said a wizard
she would not say the name
she did not want to think about all that
she wanted them all behind her no
retribution no pursuit leave them to
their hatreds put them behind her forget
now that's not really characteristic of
tenar is it she is not a person who
seeks revenge
or punishment but she's also somebody
who gets angry
at
people doing wrong in this case she's
like no no no please just i i don't want
to deal with it and we find her unable
over and over again to articulate what
is going on this is part of the
insidiousness of the spell there are
also some emotional effects she's able
to ward off one of the emotional effects
which is quite interesting
a first spell
right
we find that
there's a
an attempt to here we go
as the night that night as she lay by
the sleeping child tenor couldn't sleep
she was restless concerned with one
petty anxiety after another did i fasten
the pasture gate does my hand ache from
carding or is it arthritis beginning and
so on
then she became very uneasy
and
thinking she heard noises outside the
house why haven't i got a dog she
thought stupid not to have a dog a woman
and child living alone ought to have a
dog these days but this is ogen's house
nobody would come here to do your evil
but ogian is dead
dead buried at the roots of the tree at
the forest edge and no one will come
sparrowhawks gone run away not even
sparrowhawk anymore a shadow man no good
to anyone a dead man forced to be alive
and i have no strength there's no good
in me i say the word of the making and
it dies in my mouth it is meaningless a
stone i am a woman an old woman weak
stupid all i do is wrong all i touch
turns to ash's shadow stone i am the
creature of darkness swollen with
darkness only fire can cleanse me only
fire can eat me eat me away like and
then she
sat up and cries aloud in her own
language kargish the curse be turned and
turn
and she says you come too late aspen i
was eaten long ago go clean your own
house so the first attempt is trying to
produce this emotion of despair and
self-loathing within her
there's a lot going on here
the spell also has another effect which
is that when
aspen sets up this scenario with moss
to
lure them back saying moss is sick you
need to to come we find that she's
turned aside
on the
path to the left were the roofs of ray
albee slanting down towards the cliff's
edge to the right the road went up to
the manor house
this way tenor said no the child said
pointing left to the village this way
tenor repeated and went off on the
right-hand way ged came with her and
they walk and then they run into the one
whose name she could not remember
aspen the wizard
welcome he said and stopped smiling at
them
so he he's bewitched them and this is
where we get to the the final
confrontation
what great personages have come to honor
the house of the lord of ray alby he
said to aho that was not his name the
bone dolphin the bone animal the bone
child my lord archmage he bowed low and
get bowed to him and my lady tenor of
otto and he bowed even lower to her and
she got down on her knees in the road
her head sank down until she put her
hands in the dirt and crouched until her
mouth too was in the dirt of the road he
is abasing them with with the magic that
he has and he's going to humiliate them
as much as possible
notice that in the humiliations that he
imposes he is very concerned still with
you know with with gender and he wants
to humiliate tenar
more
than ged he ends up saying
i thought the witch would bring her
familiar with her but she brought you
instead the lord archmage sparrowhawk
what a splendid substitute all i can do
to witches and monsters is cleanse the
world of them he wants to destroy her he
hates her and and theroux
but to you
who used at one time to be a man i can
talk you're capable of rational speech
at least and capable of understanding
punishments
so
he thinks that women are not even
capable
of rational engagement and this is you
know very typical for many men not only
in his own time and the culture of earth
see but
in our own
now he also reveals something
really big
he
is a follower of the wizard cobb
who we encountered in the third novel
who had created this hole in the
universe and was promising immortality
to people he says to ged you thought you
were safe i suppose with your king on
the throne and my master
our master destroyed you thought you'd
had your will and destroyed the promise
of eternal life
didn't you
he goes on and he says what a funny
sight to see the great archmage all got
up like a goat herd and not an ounce of
magic in him
um
can you say a spell archmage no not a
word my master defeated you
now you know it you did not conquer him
his power lives i might keep you here
alive a while to see that power
my power to see the old man i keep from
death and i might use your life for that
if i need it and to see your meddling
king make a fool of himself with his
mincing lords and stupid wizards looking
for a woman this is also something that
really sticks in his craw a woman to
rule us but the rule is here the mastery
is here here in this house and then he
reveals another thing
all this year i've been gathering others
to me men who know the true power from
roke some of them from right under the
noses of the schoolmasters and from
havnor from under the nose of that
so-called son of morad who wants a woman
to rule him your king who thinks he's so
safe he can go by his true
name
and so
this is a guy who was you know clearly
aligned with the
previous evil wizard cobb who
ged had to use all of his power to not
just to defeat to let go on his way but
to undo the damage that he had done to
the dry land and to the world of the
living
and
aspen says well you're now within my
power and of course we see fortunately
even though he intends to kill both of
them he's actually going to have ged
push tenar
off of the cliff
we find that there is a happy ending to
this which involves aspen and his
followers being destroyed by the dragon
collison
called by pharaoh who is herself not a
foul imp
but actually a dragon and so the evil
wizard comes to his end but not before
he does lots and lots
of damage and if he had survived he
would have attempted to redo probably
what cobb himself had done
and
to destroy both you know roque
and the new kingship
of lebanon
you